spider-man far from home was an amazing
movie that definitely had its share of
twist to it especially the ending and
that mid-credits scene how's it goin
everyone it's worn and Marvel has
officially revealed an alternate ending
to Spider Man far from home as well as
some other alternate scenes as well so
in this video I'll be talking about the
alternate ending and alternate scenes in
spider-man far from home and why Marvel
decided to do the mid-credits scene that
they did also if you'd like a chance to
win an Iron Man helmet a Captain America
shield an Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel to enter my giveaway I'm
picking three new winners at four
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
now if you have not seen spider-man far
from home here is your official spoiler
alert as I will be talking about major
events and the ending and post-credit
scene of spider-man far from home so as
I mentioned in a recent interview
writers for spider-man 5 from home Chris
McKenna and Eric summers have recently
come out and talked about some changes
they made to spider-man far from home
including an alternate ending the first
thing that they talked about was there
was a version of spider-man far from
home where Mysteria was a villain right
from the start this version of
spider-man far from home was actually
going to be very different than the
spider-man that we saw in the theaters
writer Chris McKenna said with Mysterio
there were versions of the story where
he was at the forefront as an
out-and-out villain that Peter and Nick
were chasing around Europe as he pulled
off these events all building to this
backstory of why he was doing it which
was a wholly different third act we went
down a lot of different roads summers
then commented ultimately because
Mysterio deals so much in deception it
was sort of natural that it led to a
story structure where his entire
identity was misled for a while this
obviously makes sense for a number of
reasons including what summer said in
this interview Mysterio is a villain of
deception and illusions in the comics he
is constantly trying to trick Peter
Parker and spider-man and ultimately it
made the most sense to see him as he was
in the movie a villain trying to trick
everybody into thinking that he is a
hero
the writers then talked about the ending
and the mid-credits scene and said that
it was always a plan to reveal Peters
identity to the world
however they originally had him reveal
his identity in the final battle and not
the mid-credits scene and the interview
McKenna revealed we played with the idea
peter is the one who sacrifices his
identity out of necessity during the
final battle then it seemed more
interesting if Mysterio tricks him into
doing it but anytime we wrote a version
where he was being revealed to the world
in that battle it felt like it
diminished the victory so before it
became a tag it was really just the end
of the movie right as he feels he's
stepping up a spider-man he has the rug
pulled out from under him again so the
writers go on to talk about why they
wanted to reveal spider-man's identity
to the world and how much of an effect
it would have on future spider-man films
in the interview McKenna said we were
challenged by the producers to come up
with something that Peter sacrifices by
the end of the movie and when we hit
upon that as a group it became a very
scary idea oh no we can't do that then
it's not a spider-man movie anymore
it's such a bold maneuver that it became
inevitable particularly with a tricky
character like Mysterio who's this dark
father figure from the grave is he
trying to give Peter his I am Iron Man
moment it's thrust upon him but is this
a lesson or a punishment Sommers then
commented we were definitely debating
should we just reveal who's spider-man
is or should we frame him for something
and turn him into a pariah ultimately we
decided that both was the way to go it's
such a triumph at the end because he's
got the girl and finally earned a big
swing through the city so we want to
knock him down as far as possible so in
the next spider-man film that we're
going to get which if Sony / Marvel /
Disney sticks to what they've been doing
with the other solo spider-man movies we
should get a new one in 2021 spider-man
/ Peter Parker is going to be at the
lowest point that we've ever seen him
before
his identity has been revealed and
everybody thinks that he's a villain and
is going to be treated as a pariah so
everybody is going to go against him I
think the writers going this route
ultimately leads to a better spider-man
3 movie instead of Peters identity
coming out in a final battle it makes
more sense to have Mysterio frame him as
a villain and reveal his identity to the
world this will make a very different
spider-man than we've ever seen in the
MC with Tom Holland and will ultimately
lead to a very good story in spider-man
3 but let me know what you think about
this alternate ending where Peters
identity was originally revealed in the
final battle would you have liked to see
this or do you prefer the way that we
got it comment down below with your
thoughts and
so don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof